Speaker 1: The ugly Republican primary that
hasn't even really started yet is already so
ugly that the next year and a half is truly going
to be insane. Donald Trump is now relentlessly
pounding Ron DeSantis, who isn't even running
against him yet. And this is a fascinating
line of attack that Trump is starting to use
regarding Social Security and Medicare, because
he's effectively attacking Ron DeSantis from the
left while attacking many other Republicans from
the right. And of course, it's a reminder that
none of this is about the facts. None of this is
about reality. This is all about what can I come
up with to insult my opponents? If Trump perceives
that it's to his advantage to say you're not to
the right enough, he calls you a RINO. If Trump
finds that he actually benefits from attacking
you from the left, he'll do what he's doing with
Ron DeSantis. And let's take a look at that. And
remember, Trump is posting every single day to
Truth Social about Ron DeSantis. Censure Trump
Posting. Quote. Ron DeSantis voted three times
to cut and destroy Social Security and increase
the age requirement to at least 70. Likewise,
he voted to radically cut Medicare. He is a
disciple of RINO Paul Ryan. What do you expect?
This is so funny because calling Paul Ryan a RINO
is a suggestion that Ryan isn't right enough. But
the cutting of Social Security and Medicare being
opposed is almost like opposing something from
the left. It's it's a mishmash, unintelligible
criticism. But the most important thing is it's
really not super accurate. And as I mentioned
last week, Ron DeSantis voted three times for a
Republican Study Committee budget resolution.
This was in 2013 and 2014 and 2015. Now
those resolutions failed. If they had passed, they
were non-binding resolutions to look at pushing
the retirement age of Social Security to 70.
To be crystal clear with you. I'm against that.
Ron DeSantis seemed interested in doing it,
and it would be a fair criticism. But to say
DeSantis voted to cut Social Security is a bit of
an exaggeration. Doesn't matter. It's interesting
that this is the line of attack that Trump is
taking. Whether it's a vote for a cut kind of
depends on what you consider a vote and what you
consider a cut. But Trump's not stopping there.
Trump also now attacking Ron DeSantis by saying,
Yeah, Florida's great, but it has nothing to do
with you posting a troth in all capital letters.
Quote Florida was doing great for many years,
long before Ron DeSantis got there. The
sunshine and ocean are wonderful things to have.
And then continuing to attack the Santas who
again, remember, he's not running yet with
a post that says, quote, Polls show me doing
substantially better against hopeless Joe Biden
than Desanctis would do. An early forerunner.
It would be the 2020 election where I did much
better then in 2016, getting more votes than
any sitting president in history. That election,
however, was massively rigged. They use the
China virus, the FBI, Twitter and Facebook
and ballot stuffing in order to cheat. Good
Republicans won't let that happen again.
Get ready for a year and a half of this stuff.
And then Trump even more with the polls saying,
quote, The most recent New Hampshire poll has
me substantially leading both Ron Desanctis
and RINO Governor Chris Sununu, who the voters
in New Hampshire are getting very tired of and
unlike his father, does nothing to help the
Republican Party. Ron's cutting off Social
Security and Medicare would devastate New
Hampshire. No way they'd vote for him. Now,
what is the truth of the polling stuff? You know,
the truth is that it really varies. It is true
that Trump is polling better than DeSantis in most
polls. But the degree to which he's polling better
than the sand is really varies. In one poll, it's
25. In another poll, it's 21. But in some polls
it's Trump plus eight. There is a poll that has
DeSantis ahead. There is a poll that has Trump
ahead by only two. So it really does vary pretty
dramatically. That being said, Trump clearly has
identified to Santos as his number one contender.
The polling certainly coincides with that. So
do the CPAC straw poll results, which we'll
look at in a little bit more detail tomorrow.
But Trump is obsessed and this is what we can
expect for the next 18 months. And remember,
DeSantis hasn't even announced yet. If and when
DeSantis announces, it is going to be insane.